bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans
savourgarde au sommaire ce soir ce
nouvel ordre mondial qui se dessine de
l'Ukraine à Gaza en passant par Taïwan
l'Occident est-il capable de résister
aux ambitions de la Chine et de la
Russie on en parle avec notre grand
témoin ce soir Bruno tertret bonsoir
vous allez nous présenter votre dernier
ouvrage La Guerre des mondes mais avant
cela nous revien on sur l'intervention
d'Emmanuel Macron hier soir sur les
répercussions politiques de l'adoption
de la loi immigration est-il normal que
l'exécutif mise sur une censure de ce
texte qu'il a pourtant appelé à voter le
macronisme peut-il survivre à cette
crise le RN et les républicains en
sortent-il forcément gagnant enfin la
gauche peut-elle refaire son unité à
cette occasion on en débat avec nos
invités nous affranchi ce soir Richard
verli reviendra sur la réforme de
l'immigration de la police ti migratoire
mais au niveau européen on s'interrogera
avec pierrehenri tavoyot peut-on définir
ce qu'est la culture générale enfin
Marco Pomier reviendra sur la dernière
motion censure de l'année avant les
vacances parlementaires voilà pour le
sommaire c'est parti pour ça vous
regarde on y
[Musique]
va un président devrait pas dire cela
c'est en substance le message qu'a voulu
faire passer François Hollande à celui
qui lui a succédé il a reproché donc ce
matin à Emmanuel Macron d'avoir
encouragé sa majorité à voter une loi
tout en misant sur une censure du
Conseil
constitutionnel est-ce choquant qu'un
président assume publiquement une telle
stratégie politique c'est une des des
questions dont on va débattre avec nos
invités nous accueillons ce soir Carole
Bargeon bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes grand
reporter et éditorialiste politique à
l'OPS Didier MOS bonsoir vous êtes
professeur de droit constitutionnel
président émérite de l'Association
française de droit constitutionnel
Jean-Sébastien Ferjou bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes le fondateur et directeur de
la publication du site d'information
Atlantico Adrien broche bonsoir vous
êtes le responsable des études
politiques à l'institut de sondage via
Voice et enfin notre grand témoin ce
soir Bruno tertray vous êtes directeur
adjoint de la Fondation pour la
recherche stratégique et donc auteur de
cet ouvrage La Guerre des mondes dont on
parlera dans la seconde partie de
l'émission mais avant de débattre soyons
clair sur ce sujet c'est la mission qui
est confiée à Valérie
Brochard bonsoir Valérie bonsoir Clément
bonsoir à tous et à tous alors au
lendemain des explication du président
de la République et il reste encore
beaucoup de questions autour de cette
loi immigration et oui Clément le texte
est voté par les deux Chambres la
livraison c'est bien passé mais quand on
ouvre le carton il reste encore de trois
points qui chiffon et quand ça coince
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ben on appelle le
service tout simplement le service
aprèsvente regardez on doit se battre
contre les flux c'estàdire les arrivées
clandestine de personnes qui arrivent
sur notre territoire de manière
irrégulière c'est le premier objectif et
le deuxième c'est mieux intégré par
l'apprentissage de la langue et le
travail ce que permet aussi ce texte bon
bien c'est c'est très clair mais le
président de la République le reconnaît
lui-même et il y a encore quelques
défauts sur la machine il faudra
peut-être envisager une mise au point du
mise à jour pardon du produit ce texte
qui sort il est le fruit de ce compromis
est-ce que c'est le texte du
Gouvernement celui que vous souhitiez
non bah évidemment que non donc il y a
des choses qui me je vais pas vous dire
que je saute au plafond je les trouve
formidable ces choses il y a des choses
qui derrière par exemple bah la caution
demander honnêtement aux étudiant
étranger je pense c'est pas une bonne
idée dire parce que vous êtes étranger
on vous demande une caution c'est pas le
message de la France oui mais après ça
peut se retravailler alors ces
précisions elle ne persuad pas tout le
monde évidemment il reste malgré ses
explications un client pas convaincu du
tout de l'efficacité du produit vous
allez le reconnaître donc on on on on
accentue la pauvreté dans ce pays on
lutte pas contre l'immigration
irrégulière parce que vous pensez que
c'est parce que il y a il y a laap qui
est versé à une femme monoparentale dans
dans notre pays que des étrangers vont
traverser la Méditerranée avec les
barques risquant de mourir pour toucher
la PEL bon normal vous me direz que ce
texte ne plaise pas du tout à l'ancien
président socialiste puisque la notice
du produit serait signée par les
républicain en
personne ce texte très largement c'est
le nôtre les députés LR ont voté une
motion de rejet pour dire non nous ne
voulons pas le texte de gauche sorti de
la commission des lois totalement
dénaturé nous voulons revenir au texte
des républicains tel qu'il était sorti
du Sénat avec des dispositions
courageuses fortes puissantes qui
peuvent endiguer ces flux migratoires
qui deviennent insupportables dans le
tout dernier sondage et et là on
découvre que 70 % des Français
interrogés se déclarent satisfait du
texte et j'ai comme l'impression clément
que ce cette enquête Emmanuel Macron l'a
vu aussi regardez lutter contre
l'immigration clandestine j'ai du mal à
penser que ce serait que de droite et
quand je vois d'ailleurs l'électorat
populaire il est pour il est pour ça
quand vous vivez dans des quartiers
populaires où vous avez des difficultés
de sécurité parfois une immigration qui
est pas bien contrôlée dont vous vivez
les conséquences bah vous êtes pour
cette loi pardon mais les gens qui sont
dans les les quartiers les plus
sensibles demandez-vous pourquoi
d'ailleurs une partie d'entre eux s
parfois tourné vers l'extrême droite une
loi immigration pour faire barrage au
rassemblement national est-ce que ce
serait ça le meilleur rempart contre
l'extrême droite et bien vous me direz
ce que vous en pensez Clément et ben on
va débattre avec nos invités Merci à
VOUS Valérie Brochard on a donc bien
compris la la stratégie d'Emmanuel
Macron il assume cette loi qu'il
qualifie de courageuse il revendique de
répondre aux préoccupations des Français
mais il se défend de valider les idées
et les valeurs du rassemblement national
un petit tour de table d'abord Carole
Bargeon comment est-ce que vous l'avez
trouvé Emmanuel Macron y ce soir
convainquant plutôt parce que il assume
quand même enfin dans une première
partie en tout cas je l'ai trouvé
convaincant dans une deuxième un peu
moins mais il assume malgré tout un
certain nombre de mesures qui font
hurler l'aile gauche de sa majorité
euh il a pas été mauvais quand il il a
démontré qu'au fond euh appelons ça la
préférence nationale ou la priorité
nationale aujourd'hui était déjà en
réalité présente en France avec sur le
RSA par exemple et la prime d'activité
donc on a déjà fait des différences
entre les les des des des prestations
accordées aux étrangers et et aux
Français donc là-dessus il était pas il
était pas mauvais bon après je dois dire
que il est quand même un peu étonnant
d'entendre le président de la République
et la première ministre qui a fait à peu
près la même chose expliquer que oui le
Conseil constitutionnel va se
transformer en en chambre d'appel pour
retoquer quelques mesures qui finalement
ne lui plaisent pas a-t-il dit alors de
ça on va on va en débattre dans dans un
second temp non mais et et donc et donc
on comprend enfin on comprend qu'il a
laissé passer en fait ce texte parce
qu'il était très pressé parce que
l'usage quand même veut qu'on soumette
un projet de loi au Conseil d'État pour
que précisément il il retire ce qui est
suspect
d'anticonstitutionnalité il ne l'a pas
fait parce qu'il voulait absolument que
ce ce ce texte soit voté avant Noël pour
s'en débarrasser et et qu'on en parle
plus le problème c'est que ça va pas se
passer du tout comme ça puisque je pense
qu'on va en reparler enfin Didier MOS
nous l'exliqueraou va nous donner son
point de vue là-dessus on va on va en
parler avec lui beaucoup à la rentrée
quand même Jean-Sébastien Ferjou votre
point de vue il vous a convaincu
Emmanuel Macron vous l'avez trouvé bon
je crois qu'il y avait deux Emmanuel
Macron dans le enfin où il y avait deux
dimensions assez différentes il y en
avait une qui était sur la pédagogie de
la loi et je pense que oui il était à la
fois combatif et qu'il a réussi à
convaincre un certain nombre de gens qui
peut-être dans sa majorité avait pu être
perturbé ou au-delà de sa majorité hein
dans son électorat qui avait pu être
perturbé par les arguments parlant d'une
loi indigne d'une espèce de bascule dans
hors du champ républicain il a su
montrer et ramener à mon sens en tout
cas les choses à leur juste mesure en
montrant notamment par ce qui existait à
l'étranger là où je l'ai trouvé
infiniment moins convainquant c'était
sur la crise politique elle-même il est
dans un dénis absolu alors c'est une
posture bien sûr et on peut en quelque
sorte parfois la volonté permet ça lui a
réussi quelque foois dans le passé
permet de traverser des montagnes de feu
mais je pense que là ça ne suffira pas
et que cette espèce de dénis de réalité
concernant l'ampleur du trouble que ça
ajouté au sein de sa majorité comme le
fait tout simplement qu'il nait plus
véritablement de majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale encore moins que la majorité
relative qui est censé être être la
sienne là-dessus je l'ai trouvé et j'ai
été assez perturbé par ailleurs de
finalement ne pas l'entendre plus que ça
sur Ben un certain nombre de choses qui
me paraissent relev d'un trouble au
fonctionnement normal des institutions
au fonctionnement régulier des
institution quand vous avez la moitié
des présidents des Conseils
départementaux de gauche qui disent
qu'ils n'appliqueront pas la loi si elle
est votée madame Idalgo disant la même
chose pour la mairie de Paris il me
semble que le rôle du président de la
République prévu dans la Constitution
c'est qu'il est garant de la
constitution d'une part et du
fonctionnement régulier des institutions
je trouve que la mesure de la crise
politique n'a pas été prise Adrien BR
pas admise par Emmanuel Macron Adrien
broche cont le chef de l'État dit qu'il
répond aux préoccupations des Français
vous confirmez les les différentes
mesures qui sont contenu dans dans ce
texte sont majoritairement plébisités
par les Français aujourd'hui oui bien
sûr pour faire une petite photographie
d'opinion là-dessus on a une opinion qui
d'abord reconnaît assez peu connaître le
sujet on a si Français sur 10 qui disent
je ne sais pas bien comment c'est
question là fonctionne néanmoins une
opinion qui ne se prive pas de donner
son avis quand on les interroge ils ont
un avis et effectivement cet avis-là il
va plutôt du côté d'une demande de
régulation avec évidemment des des des
sortes d'ambivalences puisque à la fois
les mesures de régularisation sur les
secteurs en tension étit plébisité par
entre 55 et 60 % des Français et des
mesures de de plus grande fermeté aussi
en même temps donc c'est on est vraiment
sur ce sur cette dimension un peu
particulière qui répond à la question
des retraites he où l'argument était
inverse c'est-à-dire que l'opinion était
du côté de la rue le bras de fer était
entre Emmanuel Macron et la rue Emmanuel
Macron se targant à l'époque de la
responsabilité sur l'équilibre des
comptes et cetera et ces oppositions
d'avoir l'opinion de leur côté bah là on
est dans le cas inverse effectivement
Emmanuel Macron c'est un combat infra
poliitique intra poliitique l'opinion
est plutôt du côté de de ce qu'il
souhaite ou en tout cas de de la
philosophie de ce projet et les
oppositions lui opposant des principes
et cetera donc ça s'est inscrit plutôt
là-dedans et sinon je suis assez
d'accord avec ce qui a été dit pédagogie
assez bon comme comme habituellement
puis ensuite un élément intéressant
aussi on en reparlera peut-être sur le
rapport au Front national et au au à la
manière de combattre de combattre
l'extrême droite euh brudo Bruno tertr
bon la politique intérieure c'est pas
trop votre spécialité he vous sont les
relations internationales mais vous êtes
je crois docteur en sciences
politiques juste quel regard vous
portez-vous sur cette crise politique
qui a été déclenchée par cette loi
immigration je plutôt aborder sujet que
je connais bien c'est la question de
démographie politique parce que je
connais vous avez travaillé là-dessus
récemment j'ai travaillé là-dessus
récemment notamment pour l'institut
montaagne euh alors d'abord une remarque
générale moi il me semble que sans sans
prendre parti sur le texte lui-même
cette affaire montre tout de même qu'il
est extrêmement difficile sur un sujet
aussi sensible et aussi clivant de
vouloir à la fois faire bouger les
curseurs sur l'immigration légale et
faire bouger les curseurs sur la
répression de l'immigration illégale
perdu en même temps appelons on salut en
même temps si vous voulez mais le en
même temps est parfois traduit comme du
centrisme là je sais pas si c'est
vraiment un projet de loi centriste
voilà je idéalement j'ai envie de dire
qu'il aurait fallu un vrai débat sur les
besoins qu'est-ce qu'on veut comme
population active en France en 2050 de
quoi on a besoin mettre ça en relation
avec la crise de la natalité et la crise
de du renouvellement naturel de la
population aborder ce débat séparément
de la question de comment est-ce qu'on
réprime mieux l'immigration illégal je
pense que ça aurait permis peut-être
d'avoir un débat plus sain et plus
centré sur des sujets qui sont
extrêement c'est une loi sur un sujet
très politique c'est une loi très
technique même moi qui connais un petit
peu ces sujets j'avoue que je me suis
j'ai dû franchement travailler
énormément pour bien comprendre
exactement ce dont il est question et je
ne sais pas ce que les spécialistes de
l'opinion en pensent mais lorsque
l'opinion dit à 70 % qu'elle soutient
cette loi qu'est-ce qu'elle veut dire
exactement est-ce qu'elle veut dire on
est pour une politique d'équilibre
est-ce qu'elle veut dire ah oui il y a
eu beaucoup de débat sur la répression
de l'immigration illégale c'est çay ça
sera intéressant d'avir votre point de
vue sur qu'est-ce que veut dire
l'opinion quand elle quand elle approuve
à 70% ce projet la question a été posée
point par point pour pour le coup les
Français approuvent quasiment toutes les
mesures une seule de mémoire qui n'est
pas qui n'emporteut sondage donne 71 %
des Français favorables à la préférence
nationale en matière d'emploi de
logement d'allocation sociale après il y
a un aut don on parlera aussi sur lequel
j'ai un regard extérieur c'est le vieux
débat sur comment est-ce qu'on prétend
au combat combat le Front national le
fameux débat sur l'original et la copie
est-ce que ça ça voilà ça c'est un débat
sur lequelobservateur on peut aussi avir
on va en parler mais on va d'abord se
pencher sur le volet constitutionnel qui
est donc la prochaine étape qui attend
ce texte de loi puisque Emmanuel Macron
a saisi le Conseil constitutionnel
Gérald Darmanin l'a reconnu lui-même
devant le Sénat plusieurs mesures sont
je cite manifestement et clairement
contraire à la Constitution on fait le
point justement sur les mesures qui
pourraient être censurées par le Conseil
constitutionnel avec Hélène
Bonduel dans le texte transmis ce
mercredi au Conseil
constitutionnel plusieurs dispositions
pourraient être jugé non conforme à la
Constitution la plus épineuse sans doute
concerne la création de quotas
migratoires il s'agit de fixer sur 3 ans
le nombre d'étrangers admis sur le
territoire français en clair de limite
le nombre de titres de séjour les sages
pourraient considérer qu'il y a une
rupture d'égalité entre deux migrants
dans des situations similairire mais
séparé par le seuil des
quotas autre disposition les aides
sociales
conditionnées les personnes sans emploi
seront désormais soumises à un délai de
5 ans avant de pouvoir bénéficier des
allocations familiales contre 2 ans et
demi pour celles qui travaillent idem
pour les APL les allocations logement
conditionné à a 5 ans de présence en
France pour les étrangers sans emploi 3
mois pour les autres les sages
pourraient décider qu'il y a rupture
d'égalité face aux prestations sociales
voire une préférence nationale le
Conseil constitutionnel devra valider ou
non le durcissement du regroupement
familial la nouvelle loi prévoit qu'une
personne étrangère qui veut faire venir
sa famille en France doit passer 24 mois
sur le territoire au lieu de 18
actuellement pour faire la demande elle
doit aussi avoir des ressources stables
régulières et suffisantes disposer d'une
assurance maladie et avoir un conjoint
d'au moins 21 ans cette disposition
pourrait contrevenir à la Convention
européenne des droits de l'homme qui
prévoit le droit au respect d'une vie
privée et familial enfin concernant
l'article sur le droit du sol remagé il
prévoit qu'une personne née en France de
parents étrangers doit dorénavant faire
la demande pour obtenir la nationalité
française et ce entre ces 16 et ses 18
ans cette mesure pourrait être
considérée comme un cavalier législatif
c'est-à-dire concernant une autre
thématique que celle de
l'immigration les Sages ont maximum un
mois pour se prononcer sur le
texte Didier MOS d'abord sur le fond
est-ce que vous partagez cette analyse
sur les différents points de ce projet
de loi qui pourrait être donc censuré
constitutionnel tout le monde savait dès
le départ qu'il y aurait des problèmes
de constitutionnalité ce n'est pas une
surprise ce n'est pas un scoop on le
savait sur les retraites il y a un an on
le savait sur l'immigration par nature
une loi sur l'immigration quel que soit
son contenu touche aux liberté touche au
principe d'égalité touche au principe de
proportionnalité touche au droit au
regroupement familial donc j'allais là
les questions de
constitutionnalité étai présentes dès le
départ ce qui est assez original et ça
monsieur Macron l'a dit hier c'est qu'on
est parti d'un texte de 20 articles on
en est à 80 grosso modo en chiffreront
c'est-à-dire qu'il a 60 articles qui ont
été ajoutés ou en commission mixte
paritaire et qui effectivement n'ont pas
fait l'objet d'un avis du Conseil d'État
parce que ce sont des amendements
parlementaires et il faudrait arriver à
savoir dans le texte d'aujourd'hui ce
qui est du texte d'origine et de l'ajout
des débats parlementaires bon très
honnêtement je suis incapable de vous le
dire ce soir bon donc nous savons qu'il
y a des problèmes et ceux qui ont été
évoqués à l'instant sont réels bon moi
je suis incapable aujourd'hui d'avoir
une réponse précise hein je le dis
franchement pour une raison extrêmement
simple c'est que le Conseil
constitutionnel quand je suis parti de
chez moi il y a 1 heure n'avait pas
encore mis en ligne les cisines qui lui
sont adressé ni celles du président de
la République ni celles des groupes
parlementaires est-ce qu'elles sont
arrivé je n'en sais rien mais dès que je
les auraiis je les lirai et là
j'arriverai peut-être à avoir un avis
mais pour l'instant la seule chose que
je puisse dire c'est que les questions
sont évidentes qu'il y a des problèmes
de constitutionnalité et qu'il est
probable que sur l'ensemble il y aura
quelques censur mais vous dire lesquels
moi je prendrai pas le Paris ce soir
est-ce que est-ce que ça vous choque
qu'Emmanuel Macron est appeler sa
majorité à voter un texte en sachant
pertinemment que plusieurs mesures
étaient anticonstitutionnelles et même
peut-être en misant sur une censure pour
lui retirer une ép du pied moi je c'est
assez original mais rappelez-vous un
jour Jacques Chirac avec l'affaire du du
contrat premier remembache qui a dit je
promulue une nois mais je vous demande
de pas
l'appliquer jeis avoir entendu ça dans
ma voiture avoir pris Moné et appeler
certains de vos confrères en leur disant
écoutez faites quelque chose là-dessus
c'est quand même étonnant qu'un
président de la République dise ça bon
donc c'est et c'est pas la première fois
qu'un président de la République saisit
le Conseil constitutionnel non mais
est-ce que c'est est-ce que ça s'est
déjà produit que quelque part ça il m
sur une censure pour pour l'arranger
politiquement dans ce FO intérieur on
peut avoir on peut avoir des doutes mais
ça vient il n' pas de doute il souhaite
détricoter la loi par en tout cas c'est
ce qu' entendre ce qui est profondément
différent dans l'intention ça vient
fondamentalement
parlementaire s engagé et c'est
poursuivi si vous voulez quand vous avez
les les 3/4 de la loi qui en réalité
n'ont pas fait l'objet d'un avis du
Conseil d'État bon parce que ce sont des
amendements parlementaires on ne peut
pas garantir la la la conformité à la
Constitution les parlementaires de
droite ont voulu mettre un certain
nombre de dispositions est-ce qu'ils
savaient par avance que certaines
auraient des difficulté je n'en sais
rien moi je suis incapable de sonder les
cœurs et les reins mais ça existe et je
veux simplement vous dire
ch je me souviens d'un jour du temps de
Monsieur Jospin Premier ministre ça
commence à dater il y avait eu un projet
de loi sur la Corse avec la notion de
peuple corse bon et le Conseil
constitutionnel avait retoqué la notion
de peuple corse et j'avais demandé à un
de mes amis qui était un très proche de
Jospin je lu avais dit est-ce que vous y
attendiez il a dit on ne savait pas où
était la barre on ne savait pas
exactement jusqu'on on pouvait aller on
a pris le risque on a gagné sur 80 % on
a perdu sur 20 % et bien c'est le rôle
je crois ouir ce ce qui joue et je crois
je laisse la parole à Caro tout de suite
est profondément différent c'est dire
que là on a un Emmanuel Macron comme
ellisabeth Bor comme Gérald aranin qui
auprès de leur propre majorité ont dit
ça n'est pas grave vous pouvez le voter
parce que de toute façon ça sera retoqué
ce qui est autre chose que de le fait de
se poser des questions comme ça existe
sur quasiment tous les projets de loi
sur la régularité de la loi au regarde
de la Constitution là c'est assumé en
disant vous inquiétez pas vous êtes pas
d'accord ça n'est pas grave de toute
façon ça sera reté ça une par de cynisme
institutionnel qui fondément différente
il y a pas que l'argument du Conseil
constitutionnel parce que la première
ministre ellisabeth borne hier ce matin
ou hier matin à la radio hier matin a
dit par exemple et ça ça ne concernait
apparemment pas le Conseil
constitutionnel c'est que on pouvait
revenir sur un certain nombre de mesures
enfin revenir de fait en déplaçant le
curseur par exemple sur la C pour les
étudiants étrangers et ça a beaucoup
agacé par le Sénat ou mais là elle a dit
bah ça pourrait être 10 ou 20 € ce qui
est évidemment une manière de vider la
mesure de C substance nousenons nous
apprenons ce soir par ailleurs que donc
la démission de madame rotaillot la
ministre de l'Enseignement supérieur a
été refusée mais qu'elle aurait obtenu
des garantie de l'Élysée comme de
Matignon justement pour détricoter cette
mesure sur la caution donc je ne sais
pas moi je trouve que ça ressemble à une
république bananière quand le chantage à
la démission permet de dépasser le vote
du Parlement quoi qu'on pense de la
mesure sur le fond que je trouve assez
absurde enfin d'un point de vue
institutionnel s'il y a une majorité
pour voter des lois et quand à la mettre
à 10 ou 20 € autant y renoncer parce que
accessoirement c'est un coût
administratif tel de gérer ce dispositif
là que là on est vraiment en ple
j'insiste là-dessus les conditions
d'élaboration de la loi et d'adoption
dans la dernières semaines en
particulier n pas permis de faire les
contrôles de validité constitutionnell
qu'on doit faire voilà c'est
tout point vue politique estce est-ce
que Emmanuel Macron vraiment intérêt à
obtenir cette censure est-ce que ça ne
validera pas les positions de la droite
et du rassemblement national qui disent
que on ne peut pas réformer la politique
migratoire de la France sans réviser la
Constitution s tch la Constitution si
bien
sûr possible ceci étant moi je voudrais
qu'on me dise qui croit qu'une révision
de la Constitution permettrait de régler
le problème de l'immigration clandestine
moi je parle du principe qui la réalité
monsieur Macron a passé longtemps nous
expliquer qu'il y avait un principe de
réalité la réalité c'est qu'une loi ne
sert à rien contre ce qui est illégal
bon et l'immigration ce qu'on vit c'est
l'immigration illégale donc faire une
loi de plus même une loi
constitutionnelle ne servira pas à
grand-chose bon mais que il y ait
ensuite une distinction entre ceux qui
sont là depuis X années et cetera et
qu'on fasse des régularisations oui et
on retrouve le problème du curseur il
était très bien indiqué tout à l'heure
dans votre tableau est-ce que c'est 6
mois 2 ans 5 ans honnêtement c'est ce
qu'on appelle le contrôle de
proportionnalité et personne ne peut
vous dire ce qui sortira du Conseil
constitutionnel juste Adrien BR
j'aimerais vous entendre vous sur ce qui
peut s'apparenter à une forme de
manœuvre politicienne c'est-à-dire
détricoter la loi à postériori est-ce
que ça peut pas se retourner contre lui
du côté de l'opinion publique du côté
des Français qui attendaient ces mesures
est-ce qu'ils peuvent pas avoir
l'impression qu'on a leur fait à
l'envers si bien sûr et je pense que ce
serait une critique d'ailleurs bien
au-delà d'Emmanuel Macron ce serait une
critique d'impuissance politique en fait
c'est-à-dire voilà quoi que nous disent
les politiques à la limite il y a des
censures qui euh même si l'opinion à mon
avis n connaît pas grand-chose du point
de vue du du du des sages il y a une
impuissance qui fait que on bloque pour
avancer sur un certain nombre de sujets
puis auudelà ça moi je suis assez
d'accord ce qui ce qui m'a marqué dans
cette séquence c'est que le Conseil
constitutionnel même si c'est pas
forcément nouveau est devenu une
question politique le temps de quelques
heures puisque dès son discours devant
le Sénat gerérald haranin a commencé à
évoquer cette question là et qu'on était
dans une séquence où entre les les les
voies du RN qui devaient ou non être
comptabilisé qui sonen est suivi par un
débat arithmétique
les démissions annoncées de ministres si
le texte est voté je sortirai du
gouvernement ce qui pose aussi question
parce qu'à la limite si on est en
désaccord avec un texte qu'il soit voté
ou pas on peut sortir et considérer que
il y a une voilà une distinction
philosophique qui se joue et que ce
texte ne peut pas être porté par un
gouvernement dont on est membre et
l'épisode sur le Conseil constitutionnel
tout ça ouis a participé d'une sorte de
faisceau d'indice là le temps de entre
18h et et 23h30 qui qui a ajouté une
séquence
assez sur les démission des ministr pi
chev et Michel rard ont quitté les
gouvernements sur la présidence de
Franois mitan parce qu'ils étaient pas
d'accord avec certaines mesur et ils
l'ont fait voilà il fait le sujet c'est
de le dire sans le faire et que ce ne
soit pas s ou le faire mais que ce soit
refusé regardez mais pour le coup
françisoll François Hollande et c'est
comme ça qu'emuel Macron est François
Hollande et c'est comme ça qu'Emmanuel
Macron est devenu ministre avait
démissionné ou demandé à Mbour et benoî
Amon de démissionner pour des propos qui
étaient à mon sens infiniment moins ou
des critiques souenez de fameuse QV du
redressement Arna mondbourg critiquant
la politique économique du gouvernement
ce qui était moins philosophiquement
grave que d'avoir des membres d'une
majorité qui considère que vous êtes en
train de verser dans l'indignité ça
c'est quand même et rester au
gouvernement après avoir exprimé
publiquement le fait qu'on considérait
que cette loi relevait de l'indignité
franchement je ne vois pas où est la
cohérence j'imis juste qu'on qu'on
avance un peu dans le débat et sur les
les répercussions de cette crise
politique d'abord sur la majorité
elle-même Carole Bargeon est-ce
qu'Emmanuel Macron a tué le macronist en
imposant cette loi à sa majorité selon
vous est-ce que c'est la fin du de l'ADN
du macronisme
c'est-à-dire le en même temps oui parce
que là on on on voit bien que pour
répondre à une préoccupation des
Français qui s'exprime quand même enfin
confirmerit mais depuis des années des
années et des années ça n'est pas depuis
hier matin qu'on découvre que les
Français dans tous les sondages que ce
soit l'Ifop hipsos enfin et cetera votre
institut certainement euh trouve qu'il y
a trop d'étrangers en France que je sais
plus quoi qu'on se sent plus chez soi
enfin il y avait plein d'item qui ont
été étudiés depuis des années euh donc
Emmanuel Macron lorsqu'il a été élu en
2017 euh n'a pas dit un mot ou très peu
dans sa campagne en 2017 sur ce sujet-là
le régalien ne l'intéresse pas euh il
pensait que tout se réglait par
l'économie le le le ruissellement et que
au fond il y avait pas vraiment ni de
problème identitaire ni de problème
régaliens et là il est rattrapé quand
même par la
réalité donc effectivement je pense que
c'est oui c'est la fin du du en même
temps mais la fin du en même temps ça
veut dire aussi que sa majorité se
fracture est-ce qu' un risque est-ce
qu'il y a un risque d'implosion selon
vous est-ce que risque on est dans elle
est dans l'implosion là on est dans
l'implosion je pense alors sur la
question que vous posiez sur la fin du
en même temps mais il me semble que ça
fait longtemps que le en même temps est
terminé si on raisonne sur sa traduction
politique et au-udelà de ça moi je
trouve que c'est une forme de négation
de la démocratie le clivage c'est ce qui
fonde la démocratie il n'y a pas de
démocratie sans clivage mais qu'est-ce
que c'est finalement si on regarde les
nouveaux clivages c'est quoi la gauche
finalement c'est vouloir substituer la
morale à la politique et le centrisme en
tout cas celui quiincarne Emmanuel
Macron c'est vouloir substituer la
technique au politique c'estàdire de
dire finalement demandons à minse ou
appliquons des rapports de la Cour des
comptes et puis tout ira bien pour le
enfin tout ira pour le mieux dans le
meilleur des mondes et ça c'est une
forme de dénis du politique de ce point
de vue-là je ne crois pas que le
Président de la République a changé
parce que M l'inspiration même de cette
loi c'est là la distinction qu'il y a
avec les républicains il pas changé mais
la manière dont les
autres non mais Carole je suis
entièrement d'accord moi je vous dis ça
la traduction politique n'existe plus
mais lui n'a pas changé et la grande
différence avec justement les
républicains ou le rassemblement
national c'est que eux sont conscients
qu'il y a des choses qui ne sont pas
constitutionnelles mais il l'assume pour
dire regardez nous ne changerons rien à
l'immigration après on n'est pas obligé
d'être d'accord avec ce point de vu-à je
suis d'accord avec vous aucune loi ou
aucune révision constitutionnelle ne
permet de gérer le réel en soi mais au
moins sont-ils cohérents dans la
démarche en disant il nous faut en
passer par là si nous voulons obtenir
des résultats d'un mot juste ce qu'on
voit en ce moment c'est la difficulté de
Monsieur Macron de tenir sa majorité
même minoritaire et en réalité c'est un
effet de la révision constitutionnelle
de 2008 sur l'interdiction qu'il de se
représenter une troème fois on savait au
départ moi je l'ai dit en 2008 le
deuxème mandat sera très difficile parce
qu'on a l'expérience des États-Unis bon
et dès le printemps 2022 on a bien vu
que la question fondamentale pour les
députés entre guillemets macronistes
c'est qui va être notre chef la
prochaine fois on sait que ça ne sera
pas Emmanuel Macron et pour l'instant
Jean-Louis bourlange l'a dit d'ailleurs
un jour bon très honnêtement il nous
manque un chef et tant qu'ils n'ont pas
de chef et ben c'est la discipline
est-ce que Emmanuel Macron paye pas
aussi un peu la façon dont il a pu
traiter parfois le Parlement depuis 2017
on a entendu certains députés de la
majorité se plaindre que la commission
mixte paritaire se joue finalement dans
dans le bureau d'éliisabeth borne à
Matignon ça a toujours été comme ça la
révision constitutionnelle de 2008 la
vraie commission mixte paritaire bon il
y a pas une commission par au sens
formel du terme il y en a une dans le
bureau de Nicolas Sarkozy où il a réuni
les les dignitaires de la révision il
leur a dit c'est comme ça et le
lendemain tout le monde s'est écrasé et
ça a toujours été comme ça quand même
avec un bémol c'est oui effectivement
les autres présidents avaient une
pratique relativement similaire sauf
qu'ils avaient dans leur majorité des
vraies politiques qu'il y a une autre
réforme qui a eu un impact profond
c'était l'interdiction du des mandat
donc nous avons des parlementaires qui
sont des gens qui ont beaucoup moins
d'expérience politique beaucoup moins de
passé politique et donc beaucoup moins
d'épaisseur et de poids politique parce
que c'est une chose que le Président de
la République met son nez finalement
dans les affaires du Parlement CEN est
une autre qu' n'y ait quasiment plus
aucune résistance au Parlement faute
d'avoir les personnalités pour le porter
politiquement et ça ça change quand même
profondément il nous reste peu de temps
pour aborder les conséquences de cette
crise aussi pour le reste du paysage
politique français Carole Bargeon on a
vu que la droite a réussi à faire voter
le texte qu'elle souhaitait que le RN a
imposé une partie de ses idées dans le
débat public ils sort tous les deux
gagnants de cette affaire selon vous
alors euh moi je pense que
ponctuellement ponctuellement euh
LR a plutôt gagné cette séquence c'est
un projet de loi
retaillo qui dont il restera ce qu'il
restera mais en tout cas là euh ils ont
oui clairement ils ont bossé et et je
trouve que c'est c'est c'est au fond ce
sont eux qui ont gagné la séquence
Marine Le Pen euh a fait un super coup
médiatique
euh en effectivement expliquant que
c'était la victoire idéologique de son
parti et cetera mais euh est-ce si vrai
parce que on met beaucoup l'accent sur
la préférence nationale François
Hollande la l'a fait dans le monde
aujourd'hui ou hier euh mais
euh toutes ces mesures enfin beaucoup de
ces mesures était déjà dans le programme
du RPR dans les années 90 et L ces
héritiers du RPR
donc moi je pense que ponctuellement les
républicains ont gagné cette semaine
cette semaine oui cette séquence
maintenant ils n'ont pas d'accarnation
présidentielle donc ça ne veut rien dire
pour la suite d'un mot Adrien Broch sur
le le fait est-ce que c'est le meilleur
moyen de combattre les idées du
rassemblement national c'est la thèse
défendue par Emmanuel Macron c'est un
élément important de l'interview d'hier
c'estàdire si on on se replace un peu
dans la typologie des réponses au RN on
a une première réponse qui consiste à
éviter ces sujets c'est un peu la la la
la proposition que font les insoumis ne
faut pas aller sur le terrain du
régalien de l'insécurité de la laïcité
de l'immigration parce que c'est
l'argument du faire le jeu de et a un
autre type d'argument qui est plutôt
celui d'Emmanuel Macron ici qui
justement on va investir ces sujetsl et
on va essayer de de démuner le FN de le
RN pardon d'y apporter les réponses
avant c'était plutôt sur le côté
technique résultat là c'est plutôt sur
la gramère ou la manière d'aborder les
sujets parce qu'on peut très bien bien
aller sur un terrain et se dire on va
apporter une réponse républicaine à la
question de la sécurité autoritaire ouou
pas bon c'est c'est c'est cette gramère
là qui est important là effectivement il
il est dans un dans un flou et c'est je
pense le malentendu aussi du point de
vue de sa majorité qui lui reproche non
seulement d'aller sur ce terrainlà mais
en plus effectivement d'y épouser des
solutions voire d'y d'y adopter des des
mots quoi donc c'est surtout un objectif
politique totalement absurde que de
faire de la lutte contre le
rassemblement national l'objet premier
de la politique l'objet premier de la
politique c'est de répondre aux attentes
des citoyens français quand vous avez un
ministre de la Santé qui démissionne
parce qu'il a des états d'âes par
rapport aux APL ou euh je ne sais quelle
disposition de cette loi-là mais qu'on
apprend le même jour que plus de 6700 l
ont été fermés en France l'année
dernière que les services d'urgence sont
fermés dans le pays qu'il n'y a pas de
professeurs face aux enfants dans les
école il me semble que le meilleur moyen
de lutter contre le rassemblement
national ou contre n'importe quel autre
parti d'opposition c'est encore de faire
en sorte que le pays soit géré et
gouverner merci à tous les quatre d'être
venus sur le plateau de de savourgarde
c'est la fin de ce débat Bruno tertré
vous restez évidemment avec nous dans
une dizaine de minutes ce sont nos
affranchis qui vont entrer en scène avec
Richard verli on parlera politique
migratoire mais au niveau européen
Pierre-Henri tawo essaiera de définir ce
qu'est la culture générale enfin la
chronique Bourbon express de Marco
Pomier de quoi comptez-vous nous parler
aujourd'hui Marco et ben ce soir Clément
je vous parle du 31e épisode de la série
motion de censure ça passe sur LCP
depuis un an et demi mais ça commence un
peu à lasser et ça passionne quand même
nos téléspectateurs merci Marco à tout à
l'heure place à notre grand témoin à
présent Bruno tertray directeur adjoint
donc de la Fondation pour la recherche
stratégique si on vous invite c'est
parce que vous nous proposez une grille
de lecture des différentes crises qui
secouent le monde aujourd'hui cette
grille de lecture elle est au cœur de
votre dernier ouvrage que nous présente
Marco Pomier avec Baptiste gargy
Chartier si on vous invite Bruno tertré
c'est pour avoir votre regard sur ces
conflits qui s'enlisent
d'un côté l'embrasement du Proche Orient
entre le Hamas et Israël de l'autre
l'Ukraine en guerre contre la Russie
alors serait-ce un nouvel ordre mondial
vous qui prédisez dans votre dernier
livre La Guerre des mondes avec un
affrontement inéluctable entre
l'Occident et l'axe sinorusse c'est
aussi une guerre culturelle une guerre
de valeur parce que aujourd'hui
chizinping et Vladimir Poutine veulent
refaire le monde à le à leur image et
c'est un monde qui ne nous convient pas
à nous Occident
Bruno tertré vous êtes politologue
spécialiste en géopolitique et directeur
adjoint de la Fondation pour la
recherche stratégique un privoban pour
l'intégralité de votre œuvre plusieurs
ouvrages à votre actif dont l'un trait
remarqué le président et la bombe dans
votre nouveau livre vous évoquez cette
nouvelle guerre une guerre tiède une
guerre à la fois militaire mais aussi
politique économique technologique ça
sera assez différent de la guerre froide
qu'on a connu au 20e siècle et les
mondes dont je parle ce sont deux
grandes familles on va dire pas de blocs
mais deux familles une plutôt libérale
plutôt occidentale et l'autre plutôt
eurasiatique si vous voulez cette fois
vous nous plongez dans une nouvelle ère
vous analysez la tectonique des plaques
géopolitiques qui dites-vous se sont
remise à bouger pour bien comprendre
flashback historique vous évoquez
d'abord les années 1910 celle de la
compétition des empire les années 30
celle de la menace des états fascistes
puis les années 50 à avec la guerre
froide aujourd'hui la Chine et la Russie
contestent l'ordre international l'une
avec Taïwan l'autre avec l'Ukraine une
revanche contre
l'Occident aujourd'hui vous vous battez
pour nos enfants dans le donbas pour la
sécurité de notre Pat la Russie vous
parlez d'un monde ni bipolaire ni
multipolaire où se déroulera une guerre
d'influence permanente et elle pourrait
durer plusieurs décennies selon vous
alors Bruno tertray dans cette guerre
des mondes qui sortira
vainqueur alors je vais pas vous
demander de faire une prédiction
hasardeuse mais ce qui ressort de votre
livre c'est une forme d'optimisme sur
les atouts dont dispose l'Occident c'est
un peu à contre-courant de ce qu'on
entend plutôt majoritairement
aujourd'hui quels sont ces atouts pour
l'Occident aujourd'hui benah l'Occident
c'est vrai a un petit peu tendance à
s'autoflagéé et à se dire qu'il y a
quelque chose d'inéluctable au fait que
des néoempires tels que la Chine la
Russie et d'autres et bien après tout
c'est peut-être leur tour de dominer le
monde et qu'il y a peut-être quelque
chose de normal avoir un Occident qui a
beaucoup pêché qui a beaucoup fauté et
bien se prendre ses distances avec le
leadership qu'il a exercé en tout cas au
moins partiellement depuis 1945 voire
depuis beaucoup plus longtemps en fait
je crois qu'effectivement nous nous
européens nous occidentaux nous avons
des atouts nous avons alors d'abord le
fait que nous sommes des socié siété
démocratique donc résiliante plus
inventive aussi regardez je prends un
exemple très concret quelles sont les
sociétés qui face à une crise majeure
que le monde n'avait jamais connu celle
du covid-19 quelles sont les sociétés
qui ont inventé les vaccins performants
ceux qui marchaient ce avec lesquels
j'imagine vous et moi on s'est fait
vacciner bah c'est pas les Chinois c'est
pas les Russes c'est les Américains et
les Européens souvent d'ailleurs avec
des gens qui ont émigré depuis d'autres
parties du monde et donc si vous voulez
cette capacité d'inventivité de
réactivité
c'est typiquement un atout important de
l'Occident mais comment expliquez-vous
que l'universalisme par exemple soit
aujourd'hui rejeté par une grande partie
du monde que les démocraties ne soient
plus forcément un modèle qui attire que
une partie de l'opinion je vous arrête
tout de suite la démocratie
officiellement est toujours un modèle
qui attire parce que même la Russie même
la Corée du Nord se prétendent
démocratique donc vous faites vous-même
des statistiques qui montrent que il y a
de Mo en moins de démocratie libérale
dans le monde ça c'est autre chose notre
modèle de démocratie libérale tel que il
est pratique qui est dans la majorité
pas partout des pays dit occidentaux et
bien il subit une crise c'est vrai mais
il y a pas de recul massif de la
démocratie dans le monde ça n'est pas
vrai on est encore dans un monde dans
lequel depuis en gros le début du 20e
siècle il y a eu une lante avec des
accoup avec des heurs avec parfois des
allers-retours mais il y a une lue
progression de la démocratie la
démocratie n'est pas en train de tomber
elle est en crise notamment en Occident
mais elle n'est pas forcément rejetée
par les peuples vous croyez que la
majorité des Chinois et des Russes ils
veulent absolument vivre dans des pays
fchiste non je ne crois pas que ça soit
le cas ils voulaient traditionnellement
ils acceptaient l'idée de d'être
gouverné par des pouvoirs autoritaires
du moment que la
croissance l'accès au logement l'accès
au biens de consommation tiens quelque
chose qui est pas très communiste
d'ailleurs qui est plutôt qui est plutôt
une quelque chose qui vient du
capitalisme libéral était là mais lors
vous voyez les Chinois et les Russes se
révolter aujourd'hui contre leurs
dirigeants ah je les vois de plus en
plus insatisfait en Russie ça ne se voit
pas trop ouvertement aujourd'hui mais
regardz les Chinois qu'est-ce qu'ils
font d'abord ils en ont eu marre des
restrictions quasiment totalitaires
imposées par leur gouvernement pendant
le covid ils se sont révoltés c'est
parce que le pouvoir a eu peur
aujourd'hui ils sont de plus en plus en
retrait de la société ils font plus du
tout l'enfant la crise démographique
elle est d'abord et avant tout on a une
crise démographique en Europe mais elle
est d'abord et avant tout chinoise russe
et et et dans d'autres et et dans
d'autres pays du monde si vous voulez
donc si vous voulez je je ne vois pas de
révolte évidemment contre c dirigeants
aujourd'hui mais je pense que le Paris
qui consiste à dire parce que ce sont
des pouvoirs autoritaires ils ont plus
de chance d'avoir de la stabilité sur le
long terme est un Paris qui n'est pas
forcément gagnant alors dans cette
guerre tiède que vous nous annoncez que
vous nous décrivez même parce qu'elle a
déjà débuté à vos yeux vous expliquez
que le terrain militaire ne sera pas
forcément le principal champ de bataille
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui va primer
selon vous d'abord l'influence
l'influence à travers mettez quoi
là-dedans l'influence c'est gagner la
bataille des idées gagner la bataille de
la la propagande y compris avec de
fausses nouvelles des fameuses fake news
par la la conjonction des réseaux
sociaux des chaînes d'information vous
parlez de la globalisation des émotions
et du rôle je suis pas je suis pas le
seul à parler de globalisation des
émotions mais aujourd'hui c'est vrai que
dès lors qu'il dès qu'il y a une crise
ou un conflit ou quelque un événement
dans le monde aujourd'hui les réseaux
sociaux et les chaînes d'information
amplifie considérablement et rend
immédiatement accessible ces ces im et
on est armé nous l'Occident pour Baher
les discours qui peuvent être on
commence à l'être on commence à l'être
pourtant c'est une bataille qui ne fait
que commencer parce qu'on va avoir à
partir de cette année notamment dans les
campagnes électorales très nombreuses
qui vont se dérouler en 2024 beaucoup de
beaucoup de fausses de de fausses vidéos
beaucoup de fausses images générées par
l'intelligence artificielle et donc la
compétition de l'influence ça se fait
aussi à travers des batailles d'image
tout simplement l'élection américaine va
être un vrai test de ce point de vue-là
les démocraties commencent à savoir se
défendre mais c'est vrai que là elles ne
partent pas avec un atout d'avance
puisque les Chinois et les Russes se
permettent à peu près tout y compris
contre contre espèces Sonor et
trébuchant il y a il y a des agents de
ces sociétés à peu près partout en
Occident j'aimerais qu'on évoque un peu
la la guerre en Ukraine elle a eu le
mérite selon vous de dessiller les yeux
sur la réalité du régime russe sur la
nécessité d'assumer l'épreuve de force
face à nos ennemis sauf qu'on voit
aujourd'hui que l'aide occidentale
à l'Ukraine est en train de faiblir que
l'armée russe enregistre à nouveau des
succès sur le front sur le terrain
militaire qu'une réélection de Donald
Trump à la fin de l'année prochaine
n'est pas impossible est-ce que 2024
pourrait être finalement l'année de
toutes les victoires pour Vladimir
Poutine écoutez il y aura une victoire
en tout cas qui est assurée c'est celle
de sa réélection ça
c'est mais attention vous me parlez de
victoire militaire russe aujourd'hui moi
je n'en vois pas je vois des petites
tentatives limitées de l'armée russe de
reconquérir du terrain qui se solde
certes parfois par la reconquête de
quelques kilomètres carrés mais un coup
phénoménal en matériel et en homme donc
je crois que plutôt en 2024 on aura
toujours cette stabilité globale du
front mais avec un effort ukrainien sans
doute pour s'adresser d'abord à la
Crimée puisque je pense que leur
stratégie au lieu de prendre les Russes
frontalement désormais ça sera plutôt
d'essayer de les déloger de Crimée par
de multiples moyens j' j'en dis pas plus
ça sera ça à mon sens le le la question
militaire sur le terrain ukrainien de de
2020 après si et cette cette menace
d'une réélection de Donald trumpou les
Ukrainiens le savent et ils pensent déjà
depuis 6 mois donc il commencent à
s'organiser les Européens alors les
Européens justement pas encore
totalement c'est vrai que si Donald
Trump est élu au mois de novembre euh ça
forcera les Européens à prendre le
relais mais les européens font déjà
beaucoup s'ils s'organisent ils ont
maintenant 6 su 10 mois pour s'organiser
pour en gros permettre à leurs
industries de défense de connaître un
saut qualitatif dans la la production de
matériel de munitions pour l'Ukraine à
partir de janvier 2025 au cas où Donald
Trump décide de fermer tous les robinets
à mon avis ça sera pas aussi simple que
cela pour lui parce que il y a ça met du
temps si vous voulez c'est pas juste un
on appuie sur un bouton et hop il y a
plus rien qui part pour l'Ukraine mais
c'est vrai que les Européens doivent
pour que l'Ukraine puisse l'emporter
doivent se préparer à cette éventualité
euh vous avez écrit votre livre avant
que le le proche oriend ne revienne au
cœur de l'actualité comment cette guerre
entre Israël et le et le Hamas
s'inscrit-elle dans la guerre des mondes
que vous décrivez malheureusement elle
s'inscrit parfaitement dedans pourquoi
parce que ce que je décris c'est la
stratégie notamment de quatre
néo-empires Revanchistes la Russie la
Chine l'Iran mais aussi la Turquie à sa
manière qui veulent désormais avancer
leur pion contre l'Occident au sens le
plus large du terme y compris Israël qui
est quand même un pays globalement de
culture occidentale et avec des
pratiques qui sont parfois de type
génocidaire la Chine avec les Ouigours
la Russie avec les Ukrainiens la Turquie
pas directement même si elle passé
génocidaire mais en soutenant
l'Azerbaïdjan qui lui a des des
comportements de ce type de contre une
partie de la population arménienne et
l'Iran et bien l'Iran soutient le Hamas
donc ça fait bien partie de cette guerre
des mondes que je décris même si c'est
bien sûr un conflit qui a sa dynamique
propre dans ce contexte est-ce que
l'objectif militaire réaffirmé par
Benjamin netanahou d'éliminer le Hamas
il n'y aura pas de cesser le feu à Gaza
avant cette élimination du Hamas est-ce
que cet objectif militaire vous semble
atteignable oui il est atteignable alors
quand on dit éliminer ça veut dire
réduire à néant du point de vue de la
menace militaire évidemment on nélimine
jamais totalement un mouvement de ce
type vous pensez qu'on a éliminé le
nazisme en 1945 non on a réduit à néant
sa capacité de nuisance il y avait
encore des nazis en 1945 bon il y aura
encore des milisant laamass après le
problème c'est plutôt à quel prix et là
le prix que paye la population Gazaoui
peut sembler à de nombreux observateurs
et c'est tout à fait légitime exessif
par rapport à l'objectif tout aussi
légitime d'Israël qui de dire nous ne
pouvons pas continuer à vivre avec cette
menace là un mot pour conclure de la
situation de Taïwan on en parle assez
peu en France mais pour vous c'est
Taïwan qui présente le plus gros risque
d'embrasement mondial de guerre mondiale
je suis plutôt optimiste sur le risque
de guerre mondiale je pense que ce
risque est très faible parce que il y a
dans le système international ce que
j'appelle des cordes de rappel
l'interdépendance économique et
financière la disuion les alliances et
effectivement les armes nucléaires
toutefois c'est vrai que c'est là qu'il
y a le seul vrai risque de conflit
mondial parce que si chinping devait
s'emparer de Taïwan par la force les
États-Unis seraiit obligé de réagir sauf
peut-être avec Trump d'où l'importance
du facteur Trump et là il y aurait
véritablement une bataille de titan qui
s'engageraient dont les répercussions
seraiit mondiales non pas seulement
enfin pas forcément tout de suite sur le
plan militaire mais au moins sur le plan
économique commercial et financier si
vous pensez que la guerre d'Ukraine
était une guerre aux répercussions
économiques mondiales je peux vous dire
que la guerre de Tha Taiwan aurait-elle
des conséquences à peu près 10 fois plus
grandes merci beaucoup Bruno tertray je
rappelle le titre de votre dernier
ouvrage La Guerre des mondes sous titre
le retour de la géopolitique et le choc
des empires c'est aux éditions de
l'Observatoire vous restez avec nous
parce qu'on accueille à présent nos
affranchis bah qui vont rentrer tout de
suite sur le
plateau installez-vous messieurs
Pierre-Henri tawot Richard verli et
Marco Pomier bonsoir Marco bonsoir
Clément on commence avec vous de quoi
est-ce que vous nous parlez dans votre
chronique Bourbon express et ben ce soir
je vous raconte l'histoire du 31e
épisode de la série motion de censure
c'était cet après-midi dans l'émicycle
dernière motion de la séquence
budgétaire motion déposée par la gauche
en réaction au 23e 493 d'éliisabeth born
déclenché lundi pour faire adopter
définitivement le budget 2024 bon
clément je vous passe les roulements de
tambour inutile de faire durer le
suspense le gouvernement n'a pas été
renversé majorité requise pour
l'adoption de la motion de censure sur
la majorité absolue des membres de cette
Assemblée 289 pour l'adoption 116 la
majorité requise n'étant pas atteinte la
motion de censure n'est pas adoptée en
conséquence le projet de loi de finance
pour 2024 est considéré comme adopté
voilà clap de fin il était temps vous
allez me dire parce qu'il y avait plus
grand monde he honnêtement pour suivre
cette série regardez un hémicycle
quasiment vide cet après-midi et puis
dans la salle des quatre colonnes je
vous avoue vous allez le voir je me suis
senti un peu seul aucun journaliste pour
suivre la séance alors pourquoi ce ce
désintérux Marco bah c'est
l'inconvénient en fait des séries trop
prévisibles sans rebondissement ni coup
de théâtre rappelons quand même le
synopsis sa Clément par principe voter
le budget du gouvernement c'est
appartenir à la majorité pour les
oppositions c'est hors de question et
comme l'assemblée est en majorité
relative ça ne vous aura pas échappé sur
ce plateau le gouvernement déclenche une
série de 493 pour faire adopter les
différentes parties de son budget
l'oppos opposition répond motion de
censure sauf les républicains qui sont
contre le budget mais qui ne votent pas
les motions résultat le gouvernement
n'est jamais renversé mais pour
Elizabeth B toutes ces motions ça n'a
pas de sens les motions de censure sont
censé être réservées pour des moments
exceptionnels lors de la précédente
législature en majorité relative de 1988
à
1993 39 493 avait conduit à seulement 8
motions de censure voilà la première
ministre qui vise principalement la
gauche c'est la gauche qui a déposé le
plus de motions depuis le début de la
législature la France insoumise le fait
systématiquement écoutez Benjamin Luca à
quoi ça sert de déposer des motions de
censure régulièrement qui n'ont aucune
chance d'être adopté c'est un réflexe
493 é= motion de censure c'est un outil
antidémocratique il faut que les gens
qui nous regardent soient au courant
d'une chose c'est le seul outil dont
dispose l'opposition pour dénoncer
l'usage du 493 mais alors qu'est-ce
qu'on fait pour essayer de trouver un
accord sur le budget par exemple le
prochain budget en 2025 la première
ministre pourrait attendre la fin de
l'examen et le constat réel de l'absence
de majorité pour dégainer 1493 et à
minima à minima reprendre les
amendements qui ont été votés par les
parlementaires là on ne peut même pas
voter des amendements voilà Benjamin
Lucas pour les écologistes donc des
motions de censure en pagaille mais
c'est vrai que si on regarde dans les
archives c'est un outil quand même qui
semble peu efficace depuis le début de
la 5e République j'ai compté 90 motions
ont été examiné une seul a été adopté
c'était en 1962 Georges Pompidou alors
Premier ministre avait dû remettre la
démission de son gouvernement au général
de Gaulle merci beaucoup Marco Pomier on
va passer à votre chronique à vous
Richard verli bonsoir bonsoir alors il y
a pas qu'à Paris hein qu'on parle de loi
immigration à Strasbourg mercredi un
accord est enfin intervenu au niveau
européen sur ce qu'on appelle le paquet
législatif asile et migration alors mais
pour vous Richard cela ne va pas stopper
ceux qui réclament des murs pour arrêter
les migrants effectivement alors je vais
d'abord vous rappeler deux faits qui
sont particulièrement éclairants le
premier c'est le calendrier le pacte
asile et migration dont on parle sur
lequel les 27 sont enfin tombés d'accord
mercredi il avait été présenté par la
Commission européenne en septembre 2020
il y a 3 ans il doit encore être voté
définitivement par le Parlement européen
puis transposé dans leur droit pour sa
partie législative par les États-membres
bref ces mesures européennes pour gérer
l'afflux de migrants elles viennent
quand même bien tard il faut se
féliciter de leur adoption mais on est
encore loin du Big Bang d'application
immédiate qui est exigé par l'explosion
du nombre des demandes d'asile dans
l'Union il y en a eu près de 900000 en
2022 le second fait c'est la coïncidence
vous l'avez dit entre l'adoption de ce
paquet législatif européen qui
s'imposera à tous les États-membres et
le débat la veille sur le projet de loi
français ça s'est passé simultanément
avez-vous remarquez Clément qu'à aucun
moment Gérald armanin n'a évoqué la
négociation parallèle qui avait lieu à
Strasbourg c'était pourtant en même
temps rien pas un mot alors que la
gestion migratoire dépend quand même
d'abord du contrôle des frontières
extérieures de l'Union et de ces futures
règles européennes c'est le cœur du
problème on continue de faire croire que
l'immigration peut se régler au niveau
national or c'est largement faux alors
maintenant que ce texte est adopté ça
veut dire que tout va changer alors
disons que l'Union européenne prend
enfin la mesure des migrations
l'harmonisation des législations sur le
droit d'asile va pouvoir enfin commencer
la création de centes d'accueil et de
tri pardonnez-moi l'expression des
réfugiés aux portes de l'Union est
préconisé le lien effectif entre l'aide
au développement et l'acceptation par
les pays d'origine ou de transit des
migrants déboutés de l'asile va pouvoir
avoir lieu l'agence Frontex de contrôle
des frontières de l'UE va être étoffé et
il y a le fameux plan de répartition des
migrants vous savez la la nécessaire
acte de solidarité entre pays membres de
l'Union qui va être mis en œuvre le
problème c'est que la plupart des
dirigeants européens eux continue de
miser sur des solutions nationales voire
sur des murs ou des frontières hérissé
de barbelé certains refusent carrément
les solutions communautaires c'est le
cas du Premier ministre hongrois Victor
Orban le drame c'est que ce pacte sur
l'asile et l'immigration il est traité
comme une seconde ligne de défense alors
que nos frontières européennes
constituent en réalité la première ligne
merci Richard but TER trit vous vous
partager cette analyse de de Richard oui
je trouve que c'est une excellente
analyse moi j'ai j'ai beaucoup regretté
justement que alors on était en plein
débat sur la loi immigration cet
événement politique majeur après des
années de discussions il y a l'accord
sur le pacte asimmigration intervient et
on en parle quasiment pas alors que
c'est le cœur du sujet vous savez moi je
je disais en plaisantant à moitié il y a
quelques années que on a fait un petit
peu les l'erreur je je soutiens je suis
un européen comme nombre d'entre nous
mais on a fait les mêmes erreurs avec
avec le le Frontex avecvec frontière
extérieur qu'on a fait avec l'euro
c'està- direire que avant on a fait tout
l'euro sans faire de convergence
buétaire et alors qu' a fait avant alors
on a fait la libre circulation avant de
faire le contrôle des frontières ex
c'est un peu facile de dire cela mais il
y a quand même quelque chose de vrai
alors c'est c'est tout à fait juste ce
que vous dites on voit encore avec ce
qui s'est passé en Grande-Bretagne dans
les mois derniers et en Italie dans les
semaines dernières que les pays qui
votent justement pour un meilleur
contrôle de la frontière et contre
l'immigration bah sont forcés justement
d'avoir davantage recours à
l'immigration c'est en lien aussi avec
ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure sur le
déclin la natalité et donc le déclin de
la population active avec des
populations qui vieillissent dont je
partage totalement cette analyse la
question pour moi c'est de savoir si
cela aura un impact sur les élections
européennes sur le scrutin du mois de
juin est-ce que ce sont des mesures qui
seront suffisamment visibles et perçues
comme suffisamment fortes pour influer
dans un sens ou dans un autre d'ailleurs
sur le vote des électeurs européens au
mois de juin prochain c'està-dire que
vous vous craignez que opinion publique
ne se focalise que sur des mesures
nationales qui répondent à le non je
pense que malheureusement ces débats
sont devenus tellement techniques que
les électeurs malgré ce qu'on nous a dit
tout à l'heure sur la perception mesure
par mesure de la loi de la loi d'armanin
que les électeurs se définissent en
fonction de principes généraux et qu'il
seront toujours plus attirés c'est la
nature humaine par un mur visible même
s'il n'est que partiellement efficace ça
ne veut pas dire que les murs ne servent
à rien je suis pas trop dans pour cette
j'ai aussi écrit sur les frontières je
pense que les murs peuvent avoir leur
utilité les murs ce sont aussi des
symboles je pense que le philosophe ne
me démentira pas et les symboles c'est
important pour les peuples bonsoir
Pierre-Henri Tavo bonsoir alors vous
vous êtes penché sur les les résultats
catastrophiques de la France dans
l'enquête PISA consacrée à à l'école et
sur les déclarations du ministre de
l'éducation national Gabriel Atal qui a
promis je cite un choc des savoirs il
veut mettre l'accent sur l'apprentissage
de la culture générale alors vous vous
êtes interrogé sur comment définit-on la
culture générale tout le monde sait ce
qu'est la culture générale c'est ce ce
qu'il n'est pas permis d'ignorer voilà
ça suscite consensus total mais quand on
va essayer de la définir un peu en
détail là ça devient plus compliqué et
il y a une sorte de d'antinomie qui se
met en place entre ceux qui disent c'est
un SMIC culturel c'est c'est un voilà un
kit de survie on a entendu ces
expressions il y a très longtemps ou
alors ceux qui se lancent dans une liste
digne des Questions pour un champion
avec une nomenclature qui n'en finit pas
et donc c'est le trop peu ou trop plein
et on hésite entre les deux al pourquoi
est-ce qu'il est aussi difficile de
définir le contenu faut prendre un peu
de recul en fait la notion de culture
générale date de 1905 c'est la loi sur
l'enseignement secondaire en France et
c'est le moment où on va substituer
justement à la culture des humanités la
culture la culture générale les
humanités c'est vraiment très très
élitiste c'est siiceron qui dit voilà
les humanités c'est ce qui rend l'homme
encore plus homme mais aussi ce qui peut
le sauver parce que en lisant des œuvres
éternelles et bien d'une certaine façon
il y a une parcelle de cette immortalité
qui revient sur lecteur donc c'est
quelque chose qui est presque religieux
les humanités la culture générale c'est
beaucoup plus modeste la culture
générale c'est plus utilitaire plus mord
il y a il y a des sciences donc la
perspective de Salus disparaît un peu
donc cette culture générale qui est plus
démocratique en un sens et bien se
trouve immédiatement confronté à deux
types de critiques d'un côté la critique
j'allais dire à la fin kelcot
c'est-à-dire bah ça la démocratie ça
égalise bah si ça égalise il y a plus de
culture parce que bah un rap vaut madame
Bovari un tag vaut Léonard de Vinci
voilà et donc au fond la culture
disparaît dans la démocratie à l'inverse
et là je vais faire du Bourdieu euh pas
du tout c'est au contraire la démocratie
c'est la culture générale qui menace la
démocratie parce qu'en définissant la
culture générale comme ce qu'il n'est
pas permis d'ignorer on crée des délis
d'initié il y a ceux qui savent et puis
ça que ceux qui savent pas ceux qu'on
les code et ceux qui n'ont pas les codes
ne vont pas rentrer dans l'ascensur
sociale alors est-ce que ça veut dire
que définir la culture générale c'est
une mission impossible al je crois que
c'est possible simplement il faut se
mettre d'accord sur le fait que c'est à
la fois un contenu et une méthode il y a
un contenu il faut le rappeler il faut
savoir des choses il faut même savoir
des choses par cœur des dates des cartes
des œuvres des récits tout ça il faut il
faut le savoir simplement on peut pas se
lancer dans une liste parce que la liste
sera forcément manquante déficiante et
puis le but de la la culture générale
c'est pas l'érudition le but c'est
vraiment de mettre les savoirs en
culture et c'est là que la méthode
intervient qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
méthode dans la querelle des anciens et
des modernes au 16e et 17e siècle il
avait une très très belle métaphore qui
opposait les fourmis les araignées et
les abeilles alors la fourmi c'était
l'archétype de l'ancien c'est celui qui
lit qui accumule qui accumule mais sans
rien produire c'est les rudis stériles
l'araignée c'est le synonyme des
modernes c'est celui qui n'a pas besoin
des autres qui se débrouille tout seul
qui déduit tout de d'elle-même elle
produit sa toile à partir de sa propre
bave et puis il y a l'abeille alors
l'abeille c'est l'idéal parce que
l'abeille a besoin des fleurs pour
butiner elle va chercher comme ça et
puis elle en fait le miel comme dit
Montine qui est tout tout leur tout tout
sien et donc c'est ça l'étymologie du
mot examin est intéressante examin en
latin ça veut dire les seins les seins
d'abeill dites ça vos enfants quand ils
passent des examens c'est formidable il
y a la ruche qui est là le cerveau puis
on va hop envoyer les abeilles
exploratrices allz cueillir des choses
sur les fleurs ramener le nectar et on
va faire le miel c'est-à-dire la
dissertation en 4 heur c'est formidable
c'est magnifique et bien c'est ça la
culture générale c'est l'art sérieux du
butinage voilà comment on pourrait la
définir et je vrais juste terminer avec
cette phrase du moraliste jbert qui est
mort en 1824 qui regrettait on s'entend
déjà la disparition de la culture
générale mais qui disait la chose
suivante on sortait des anciennes écoles
avec une ignorance qui se connaissait et
un savoir qui s'ignorait on les quittait
à vide de sa encore et plein d'amour et
de respect pour les hommes qu'on croyait
instruit bref on pourrait dire qu'on a
de la culture générale quand on mesure
l'ampleur de son ignorance mais écoutez
c'est une très belle définition d'un mot
Bruno tertray vous avez votre propre
définition de la culture générale la
seule chose que j'ai appris et que je
continue à transmettre je l'ai appris
très tôt dans mes études c'est que
savoir dire je ne sais pas et le dire en
toute franchise et très honnêtement et
sans dire eu eu voilà je ne sais pas
c'est ça n'est pas une preuve
d'ignorance c'est enfin c'est aussi en
tout cas une forme j'espère
d'intelligence etess de transmettre ça
voilà savoir dire je ne sais pas merci
beaucoup à vous Bruno tertrè je rappelle
donc le titre de votre ouvrage La Guerre
des mondes le retour de la géopolitique
et le choc des empires aux éditions de
l'Observatoire merci à notre équipe
d'afranchi également à tous les trois
demain c'est la dernière de l'année pour
ça vous regarde ne ratez pas le
rendez-vous on fera le bilan de cette
année parlementaire particulièrement
riche bonne soirée à tous et à
[Musique]
demain